[Musique]
bienvenue sur FRANCE 24 vous regardez le
journal de l'Afrique toute l'actualité
du continent africain c'est tout de
suite
pas encore de résultats officiels au
Sénégal après les législatives de
dimanche pouvoir et opposition
s'attribue toujours la victoire
elimandao nous attend à Dakar
trois civils tués dimanche dans le
nord-est de la RDC par des casques bleus
de quoi mettre de l'huile sur le feu la
Monusco la mission de l'ONU est
contestée dans la rue depuis une semaine
et puis 32 personnes brûlées vivent dans
un village de Madagascar la police
recherche les coupables elle impute ce
massacre à des voleurs de bétail France
24 s'est rendu sur les lieux
patience et mère de sûreté dit-on et
pour savoir qui a remporté les
législatives au Sénégal il faudra donc
encore patienter les résultats officiels
devraient être annoncés d'ici vendredi
en attendant c'est la bataille des
chiffres et des déclarations opposition
et qu'en présidentielle s'arrogent la
victoire la première peut imposer au
second une cohabitation à Dakar le
correspondant de France 24 et limenda au
bonjour Eliman beaucoup d'impatience du
côté de la population
écouter une attente irrespirable depuis
dimanche la fermeture des bureaux de
vote les Sénégalais oui vaca leurs
occupations depuis ce jour-là mais ont
toujours un peu à l'oreille la radio
pour écouter les dernières informations
sur ce scrutin mais également en
regardant les réseaux sociaux avec
notamment les résultats publiés par la
plateforme de la société civile menée
par des blogueurs Sénégal vote qui
publie des résultats
issus des procès verbaux des commissions
départementales de recensement des votes
une attente irrespirable et actuellement
on va
on sera dans quelques dans quelques
heures la publication définitive de
toutes les listes de toutes les de tous
les résultats
issus des du scrutin par département
les commissions nationales
départementales plutôt de recensement de
votre ont jusqu'à minuit ce soir pour
publier ses résultats
inédit et c'est un peu sur toutes les
lèvres les deux principales grandes
forces politiques la coalition au
pouvoir Benoît car elle a coalition de
l'opposition à toutes les deux cris
victoire pense avoir la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'opposition
ce lundi face à la presse à estimer
avoir eu le nombre de voies nécessaires
pour avoir 83 sièges à 83 sièges
garantirait la majorité à l'opposition
le pouvoir de son côté ne croit pas
assez déclaration de l'opposition et
estime en ayant remporté beaucoup plus
de départements que l'opposition à
passer devant mais il faudrait dire que
le point électoral des départements
remporté par l'opposition sont beaucoup
plus importants le suspense reste entier
vous l'avez dit ce serait inédit si il y
aurait cohabitation au Sénégal jamais
dans l'histoire politique du Sénégal une
cohabitation n'a eu lieu il faudrait
dire également que le pouvoir a perdu un
peu du terrain par rapport aux dernières
législatives de 2017 le pouvoir raconter
à 125 députés à l'Assemblée nationale
sur la législature sortante actuellement
selon les chiffres les projections que
l'on voit ça et là il risque de perdre
au moins jusqu'à 40 députés ce qui a
donné encore du poids à l'opposition qui
est en train de confirmer une percée
historique merci
24 à Dakar la capitale sénégalaise en
Guinée phonique et manga Ibrahima Diallo
et Saiko Yaya Barry ont été écroué à
Conakry les deux premiers sont membres
du fndc le troisième de l'UFR tous
appartiennent à l'opposition ils ont été
inculpés notamment pour participation à
un attroupement interdit et destruction
de bien public en l'occurrence les
manifestations interdites contre la
jante organisée la semaine dernière cinq
personnes qui ont été tués Malik Diakité
le correspondant de France 24
du Front national pour la défense de la
Constitution
Ibrahima Diallo chargé des opérations et
seikouya Bari secrétaire exécutif de
l'Union des fausses républicains le
parti de l'ancien Premier ministre s'il
y a Touré ont été entendus selon dit
pendant juste d'instruction au tribunal
de première instance de dix-seine les
trois opposants ont été ensuite placé
sous mandat des dépôt à la prison
centrale de Conakry ils sont accusés
pour des faits présumés de participation
à un attroupement interdit destruction
de bien public et privés coûts et
blessures volontaires lors des
manifestations violentes qui ont eu lieu
à Conakry j'ai dit et vendredi et qui
ont fait au moins 5 morts 9 autres
jeunes manifestants poursuivi pour les
mêmes faits ont été condamnés à 6 mois
de prison avec sursis et au paiement
d'une amende de 500 000 francs guinéens
chacun soit environ 60 euros le Front
national pour la défense de la
Constitution dénonce au jeu cite une
instrumentalisation de la justice par
les militaires au pouvoir
les mouvements en menaçant d'appeler à
de nouvelles manifestations dans le jour
à venir pour exiger la libération de
tous les détenus
que s'est-il passé dimanche à casting 10
Post frontières entre l'Ouganda et la
RDC trois personnes sont mortes sous les
balles des casques bleus 14 ont été
blessés mais le contexte est flou
l'incident s'ajoute en tout cas au
manifestations violentes de ces derniers
jours dans le Nord qui vous contre l'ONU
bilan 30 morts j'ai inefficace la
Monusco et persona dans le gratin
Laurent Berchet
blessé par balle lors de la fusillade ce
jeune homme affirme avoir été
directement visé par des soldats de la
Monusco
appartenant à la Monusco
dimanche des casques bleus ont ouvert le
feu au poste frontière de cassindi
faisant au moins trois morts et une
quinzaine de blessés la fusillade dont
les motivations et le contexte restent
flou a suscité colère et incompréhension
en RDC elle a été vivement condamnée par
les responsables onusiens qui affirment
avoir arrêté les auteurs des tirs en
attendant les conclusions de l'enquête
un contingent militaire a également été
dépêché sur place par les autorités
congolaises afin de rassurer une
population encore sous le choc
le gouvernement ne peut pas abandonner
son peuple c'est pour cela que je suis
là avec vous et les autres en attendant
qu'on puisse suivre leurs soins
ce dernier incident intervient dans un
contexte déjà extrêmement tendu entre la
population congolaise et la mission des
Nations Unies en RDC depuis une semaine
les manifestations se multiplient à
travers le pays pour réclamer le départ
de cette mission accusé d'inefficacité
dans sa lutte contre les groupes armés
lundi soir Félix Tshisekedi a
officiellement demandé la tenue d'une
réunion avec les responsables de la
Monusco pour réévaluer son retrait du
pays
les froid à Madagascar 32 personnes dont
15 enfants brûlés vivent au sein de leur
maison le drame a eu lieu à ankazoubet
dans la province de Tananarive la
capitale 5 suspects ont été arrêtés mais
la police recherche d'autres coupables
elle soupçonne les dalous ses voleurs de
bétail notre équipe s'est rendu sur
place
un amas de cendres de chair et de
vêtements brûlés c'est tout ce qu'il
reste de cette nuit meurtrière le 29
juillet dernier à l'aube 32 personnes se
réfugient dans cette maison pour
échapper à l'attaque d'une douzaine de
dahral des bandits de grands chemins un
fléau à Madagascar les assaillants
incendies la maison 29 personnes dont 15
enfants sont brûlés vif c'est le tiers
des habitants de ce petit village
aujourd'hui déserté Albert a été témoin
du drame
les DALO ont brûlé cette maison là bas
et moi je me suis caché dans cette
maison et dès que la maison a volé ils
ont entouré la maison pour que les
personnes dedans ne puissent passer par
la fenêtre
père de 27 ans un des seules survivants
il a échappé au feu en sautant par la
fenêtre sa femme et ses quatre enfants
sont morts quelques mois plus tôt son
père mourrait abattu en allant au marché
la cause c'est le fait que mon père
était proche des dirigeants quand il y
avait des personnes au placées proches
du pouvoir qui venaient dans notre
village elles étaient accueillies chez
mon père et les DALO considéraient cet
accueil comme une dénonciation
des villages qui s'entrent des chiffres
rongés par la criminalité c'est devenu
le banal quotidien de nombreux malgaches
en zone rurale au point que les forces
de l'ordre ont négligé les alertes de
doussoua cette fois il décide de se
protéger à l'aide d'amulette
lorsque les gendarmes font des descentes
là-bas on arrive jamais à attraper les
DALO ils arrivent toujours à s'enfuir et
les gendarmes ne me croient plus comme
si je mentais j'ai préféré à faire appel
aux gens qui font du grigri dans le
village
le président a promis justice et
exemplarité mais l’armée malgache n'a
jamais réussi à mettre un terme à ses
conflits meurtriers les dahals sont de
plus en plus puissants enrichis par le
vol de zébus et protégé par des
autorités corrompues un cocktail
explosif qui sans politique de
développement pourrait constituer les
prémices d'une guerre civile
Abdoulaye meskin fait face à la justice
tchadienne c'est lui qui a fondé le
Front démocratique du peuple
centrafricain un groupe armé rebelle
accusé notamment d'avoir créé un
mouvement azurrectionnel il a été arrêté
il y a trois ans le Tchad refuse depuis
son extradition vers la Centrafrique ça
demande de remise en liberté a été
rejetée les détails avec Mamadou Jimmy
nouveau rebond du chemin lors du procès
d'Abdoulaye miskine et de ces trois
compagnons le procès du chef rebelle
centrafricain a commencé le vendredi 29
juillet et aujourd'hui ça demande de
mise en liberté a été rejetée le parquet
craint des trouble à l'ordre public ces
avocats ne comprennent pas cette
décision on écoute maître
ce matin
la chambre criminelle
vient donc de se prononcer par rapport à
la demande de mise en liberté d'office
des accusés
la Chambre a donc rejeté cette demande
sans de cette demande qui a été rejetée
je ne peux pas entrer dans la conscience
du juge
je n'ai pas
je n'ai pas l'arrêt avant de retirer
cette demande
le seul les motivations de juge nous
permettrait de voir si le droit a été
dit ou pas mais pour notre part nous
tenons à signaler que
audience
a eu lieu
ça la notification de l'ordonnance de
prise de corps aux accusés
Abdoulaye miskine ont été arrêtés à la
frontière Tchad RCA en octobre 2019 ils
sont incarcérés en diamina depuis juin
2020 les charges retenues contre eux
sont lourdes création d'un mouvement
insurrectionnel enlevément séquestration
assassinant entre autres Bangui a
toujours réclamé sans succès
l'extradition du fondateur du Front
démocratique du peuple centrafricain
FDPC le verdure de leur procès est prévu
pour le 7 août prochain
si vous passez par Cotonou vous ne
pourrez pas la manquer une Amazon en
bronze haute de 30 mètres symboles de
celles qui ont défendu le royaume du
Dahomey l'ancien Bénin la statue fait la
fierté des habitants de la ville sur
place Emmanuel Sadji pour France 24
vous savez il y a encore 3 mois à un 7
statue qui représente une Amazon et bien
elle était même pas encore découverte
que déjà elle faisait sensation sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien depuis quelques
jours c'est officiel elle représente
l'emblème du Bénin cette statue qui
représente une Amazon c'est une statue
qui est recouverte de bronze sur 30
mètres elle est en structure métallique
au cœur de la ville c'est ça qui fait ma
fierté on en a tellement parlé d'elle
dans nos histoires dans les écoles mais
on n'a jamais su qu'un jour on pourrait
la voir
et j'aime bien parce que ça représente
[Musique]
le monument est un hommage au régiment
des femmes militaires de l'ancien
royaume de la Romé un régiment qui a été
créé au tout début du 18e siècle par la
seule femme reine du royaume Tassy en B
le monument de l'Amazone a été inauguré
par le chef de l'État béninois
attristallon ce qui importe
c'est que sur la terre du Bénin
les mots courage bravo force combativité
et honneur
ne sont pas exclusifs
aux gens masculins au Bénin
autant que les hommes des femmes se sont
distinguées par ces valeurs et ont brisé
le mythe du sexe faible
d'Amazon est en train de devenir un
véritable pôle d'attraction touristique
en fait les autorités misent leur
développement économique sur le
patrimoine culturel d'ici 2026 elles
entendent de faire du Bénin une
destination majeure
merci de fidélité au journal de
l'Afrique merci aussi aux équipes en
régie et en rédaction l'actualité du
continent s'est a retrouvé également sur
France 24.com et nos réseaux sociaux
restez avec nous à demain
[Musique]